This video is brought to you by news voice, the news.
He's broken almost all us media is owned by just a handful of big corporations.
Fake news is obviously a huge problem as well.
And finding something unbiased can be hard.
News voice is revolutionizing the news landscape.
It's an app that gives you a personalized newsfeed by aggregating major news
sites, as well as international and independent media,
given some much needed balance. Each new story shows multiple sources,
which are all tagged with their bias and perspective.
The news affects almost everything in our lives. What we hear and read shapes,
which persons we trust, what we eat, what we buy, how we vote,
and even how we think news voice is created by its readers.
As you can vote stories that you find interesting. So more people will see them.
It's essentially a democratized platform for news. Plus it saves you time.
You get all the news and all the sources in one app.
So you can be better informed. Oh, add it's totally free. Anyway,
get started with news voice today for free through the link below it's available
on both Google play and Apple app store. And let's get into the video.
Yeah.
2020 Is advancing as fast as the Corona virus is spreading.
Then the third is getting closer and closer.
That means the U S election is coming up.
Friends going to the polls after a president's first term is always kind of like
a referendum on how the current administration is doing.
But if we also take into account the enormous role that the current tenant of
the white house has played during this term,
then we find that these elections promised to be a referendum on Donald Trump
himself and difference of visual politics. Donald J.
Trump is at the time of making this video going through one of his worst periods
as president.
He faces a pandemic with more than 165,000 debt with economic hardships,
for millions who have lost their jobs.
And with the streets filled with massive protests against institutional racism
for one reason or another.
The fact is that the end of his term is proving to be worse than anyone could
ever have imagined.
So in view of this, I think it's time to take a look at the alternative.
Let's see what the democratic party and its presidential candidate,
Joseph Robinette Biden Jr.
Better known as Joe Biden have to offer a bomber's form.
Former vice-president seems to be a bet on moderation, a bet on stability,
but who exactly is Joe Biden? How long has he been in politics?
What exactly does he stand for more importantly,
what can he bring to the United States on visual politics today?
We are going to answer all these questions,
but first we're going to take a look back at some history.
A lifetime in politics.
Joe Biden is a native of Scranton, Pennsylvania,
a super boring little town that became famous as the setting for the popular
comedy series, the office, if you haven't seen it, write that one down.
Joe Biden is the perfect example of what it means to be a professional
politician. In fact, it is said that when he was a baby, he didn't cry.
He gave speeches.
And if Bernie Sanders has been in politics for half of his life,
Biden can go one better before becoming vice president.
He was a Senator for the state of Delaware and no less than 36 years.
Just to give you an idea.
He took office almost as soon as he celebrated his 30th birthday,
which by the way, is the minimum age required to be a United States,
Senator and friends. Since he first sat in the Senator chair,
he did not budge until 2009.
When he became a bombers vice-president during his eight years in the white
house. But let's start back at the beginning.
Joe Biden was born in 1942 a time when battles like Guadalcanal or Stalingrad
were being fought around the world.
He was the first born of an Irish Catholic family.
And when Joe was just 10 years old,
the Biden family sought to improve their economic situation by moving to
Claymont a town in Delaware where Joe completed his studies before going to
college, it was here that Biden spent most of the 1960s.
He first did a double major in history and political science at the university
of Delaware, and then went on to study law at the Sierra.
University. And of course.
Leave the stereotypes. And you add university life duties, his Irish background,
you would perhaps imagine a young Biden going on a binge of debauchery paved in
alcohol, wouldn't you? Well,
no that wasn't the case because Biden doesn't drink, which we celebrate,
but which on the other hand is no guarantee of anything I've ever.
America will have a T total or president and either Donald Trump or Joe Biden.
The fact is that in 1969,
after his college years Biden began working as a lawyer at about the same time.
He also began his political activity in the democratic party as a member of the
new castle County council. We're talking about the year 1970.
This was the first step before launching his candidacy for the Senate.
Just two years later in the elections of 72,
Those were bad times for the democratic party,
but young Biden achieved the impossible.
He took over the post from a very experienced Republican Senator.
That's a time when Richard Nixon was taking the presidential elections by storm.
Biden is not an academic. He's not a theoretical thinker. He's a great St. Paul.
He comes from a long line of working people in Scranton auto salesman,
car dealers, people who know how to make a sale. He has that great Irish gift,
Howard Fineman, former chief political correspondent at noon.
Unfortunately, however,
a joy in the Biden household quickly faded before he even took office.
As Senator Biden's wife was in a car accident that cost the lives of herself and
her daughter. The accident also puts the other two Biden children in hospital.
At this point, it is said that good old Joe was on the verge of resigning,
but the Democrats insisted that he continue making it into the Senate before the
Republican roll call was a symbol of change.
And the new generation of politicians would have to prevail in the post Nixon
era.
Politics is a matter of personal honor. A man's word is his bond.
You give your word, you keep it. If you do politics the right way,
I believe you can actually make people's lives better.
And integrity is the minimum ante to get into the game, Joe Biden,
but let's keep.
In 1997, he became chairman of the Senate judiciary committee,
a period that he took advantage of to push through tough legislation,
to combat crime,
organized crime and drug trafficking legislation that even included the death
penalty.
This is certainly noteworthy since he now proposes abolishing the death penalty,
of course thinking is evolving naturally. It does, by the way, in 1991,
he also conducted to the investigations of the candidates.
Clarence Thomas ahead of his appointment as judge of the Supreme court,
Thomas will undoubtedly go down in history for his harsh tone against Anita
Hill. The woman who accused the later confirmed judge of sexual harassment.
To this day,
I regret I couldn't come up with a way to get her a kind of hearing.
She deserved given the courage he showed by reaching out to us
in any case.
It is not change is Biden's objective because Biden always had one destination
in mind, the white house,
You know,
when Biden announced his first democratic primary run way back in 1987,
well positioned for his restraint and with an ability to raise funds for his
campaign Biden, nevertheless lasted barely two and a half months in the race.
He was accused of copying speeches by British labor politicians and even
president Kennedy himself.
When it became public that he had already had incidents of plagiarism during his
university days, Biden had no choice, but to pull out.
The race such as life.
These luck changed again.
When the new century brought him the chairmanship of the powerful Senate foreign
affairs committee Biden had been a strong advocate of military intervention in
the Balkans against Milosevic after the nine 11 attacks.
He did not hesitate in working with the Republican administration of George W.
Bush to support the attack on the Taliban in Afghanistan first and later on
Saddam Hussein's regime in Iraq.
And although he later acknowledged that he was wrong,
this can be read into ways for critics of the war,
a majority group in the democratic party.
It is clear that he was wrong and it is a burden on him. But on the other hand,
it shows us a politician who has no problem working with the Republicans to
reach consensus and that that's in the current times, couldn't be a very,
very valuable asset as we will see.
In 2000.
Biden relaunched his candidacy for the democratic party,
but he didn't make it past the first vote.
He came in fifth in Iowa and saw that he had no chance against candidates like
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton. However,
Obama who had barely been in Washington for three years as a Senator bet on
Biden's experience his moderation and his knowledge of foreign policy to offer
him the spot on his ticket as a candidacy for vice versa.
And the tree.
If he's there, he was a very popular vice-president and yet, well,
let's be honest.
Biden's profile would have been very badly received four years ago in an
election dominated by Trump. In other words,
he would have been no match for a popular businessman who appears on TV facing
off against the political cost that is pulling the strings in Washington.
However, in November,
2020 is moderate approach and all his experience in management,
maybe Biden's main selling points in these times of coronavirus and crisis.
The.
It will be a true referendum on Trump and the alternative to the current tenants
of 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue is the Pennsylvania man,
Joseph Robinette Biden Jr.
A politician well-known to all Americans who promises to leave behind the
tumultuous era of the Trump administration and who will also have the support of
those nostalgic for Obama. And of course the former president himself.
The kind of leadership that's guided by knowledge and experience,
honesty and humility, empathy, and grace,
that kind of leadership doesn't just belong in our state capitals and mayor's
offices.
It belongs in the white house and that's why I'm so proud to endorse Joe Biden
for president of the United States.
If the death of his first born son took him away from the 2016 presidential
elections. Now after two failed attempts,
he has a real opportunity to finally take his place in the oval office.
Of course.
Well, some people wonder if Biden isn't a little too late to the party because
friends, if he does win the election,
he will be 78 years old when he takes the office 78 years,
which by the way is about the same as the average life expectancy in the United
States. It's certainly an advanced age by any standards.
Of course the alternative is not so different at 74.
Trump is along with Reagan, the oldest president seeking re-election friends.
It's clear that this is no game for the young, the times are progressing.
And certainly don't think that such an advanced age necessarily implies having
old fashioned ideas as movements have emerged within the democratic party.
Biden has.
How shall I put it step to the left to keep up with the times listen app?
I shouldn't say it on time. Um, I, I like speed
sounds good
strengths in unity.
At first glance, Biden might not be the best candidate in the world.
You only have to see him for a minute to know that he is not the life of the
party or the best person to mobilize voters.
But at this time that's kind of working in his favor.
The health and economic crisis caused by the Corona virus has worn Trump down,
much more than his usual eccentricities and outbursts were ever able to do.
Let's not forget. That's the presidential team that takes the office in January.
We'll have to deal with the destruction of the 42 million jobs caused by the
Corona virus. So far a huge budget hole,
courtesy of four years of the Trump administration and a rather complicated
international relationship. Yes,
the current situation is terrible for the United States, but friends for Biden,
it's quite an opportunity.
Biden camp finds selling point in alien economy. His work on 2009.
Similarly,
the Obama administration was faced with the effects of the great recession as
soon as it took office.
And vice-president Biden was personally responsible for administering the
stimulus launched by the white house,
a stimulus plan of nearly $800 billion.
So Biden can trade on the fact that he has already faced a scenario like this
and that things didn't turn out so badly.
[Inaudible].
Of course, despite whether you agree with this kind of policy or not,
we can't deny that such experience is a better credential than virtually any
speech a candidate could make,
especially when you're not the most skillful at choosing words, take,
for example, what happened to Biden when he talked about violence against women?
No,
man has a right to raise a hand to a woman in anger
other than in self-defense and that's rarely ever occurs.
And so we have to just change the culture period and keep punching at it and
punching and punching it.
You couldn't come up with any better word.
So what is the biggest potential obstacle facing Obama's former vice president?
Well,
the Hillary Clinton effect that is that's what happened in 2016 will happen
again when a good part of Sanders democratic supporters refuse to vote for the
Democrats and a few even voted for Trump. But then again,
things have changed in 2016.
On one hand, let's be honest.
There's nothing uniting the democratic party more right now than the desire to
avoid four more years of Trump. And on the other hand,
because Biden could end up offering a candidacy more to the left than Hillary
Clinton offered.
This is something that we've discussed in previous visual politic videos,
the great success of Sanders Warren and rising stars like Acacia Cortez would be
to move the democratic party much further to the left and exchange for their
support. That is their votes. And it seems that's exactly what has happened.
For example,
Hillary Clinton's proposals to expand the healthcare program known as Obamacare
were to cost $200 billion over 10 years by didn't put nearly four times as much
on the table with plans reaching $750 billion.
Another difference is that the Democrats no longer label initiatives,
such as doubling the minimum wage as radical a $15 an hour minimum
wage as long overdue, but it's just the start.
We have to make sure every single worker receives the pay and dignity they
deserve and friends,
let's not fool ourselves in this pandemic era defending and even expanding
Obamacare could be a very, very popular drawcard. Then again,
getting close to the proposals in Sanders manifesto would require several
federal budgets to support that much spending. In fact,
it was precisely the radicalism of Vermont socialist candidates that led
moderate democratic candidates to withdraw from the primaries race in order to
clear the way for the more moderate Biden. And yes,
it is true that Biden's positions are still far from those of Sanders,
but they clearly have moved closer. So the question is,
how does Biden expect to finance his campaign promises?
Is he going to raise taxes? Well, yes, he will.
At least that's what he's advocating in a very moderate way. Of course,
Biden is proposing to restore the highest tax rate to 39.6%.
For those earning over $400,000, Trump lowered it to 37%.
He also pledges to raise corporate tax from 21% to 28%. Whereas before Trump,
it was 35%. In any case,
what is not in his plan is to boost public spending as much as Sanders advocated
or to adopt debatable economic theories that could have serious consequences for
inflation. Like the modern monetary theory.
Know.
Perhaps raising taxes too much in these times of economic crisis just may not be
the best idea, but as you can see, his measures are far from radical.
And as we all know,
campaigns are one thing and the presidency is quite another because in this
election,
Biden may have to pitch his speeches more to the left than he would like to in
order to ensure the vote of Sanders and company.
But the truth is that Biden has always represented the ideological center of the
Democrats. In fact, he was a Senator for Delaware,
a state that many accused of being a tax Haven and which we recently talked
about here on visual politic. I'll leave you with Lincoln,
the description friends for out a very, very long political career,
but I didn't have defended conservative positions on abortion on some racial
issues. And as we mentioned earlier, he not only defended,
but proposed a strong hand in fighting crime. In other words,
he ticked all the boxes to be a majority candidate in the United States,
but of course, as the center of the party moved to the left.
So did he have that, that brings us straight to the key question.
What can we really expect if Joe Biden becomes the 46th president of the United
States? Well, let's see.
Joe Biden's America.
Slight tax increases much more health spending stimulus plans and the push to
raise the minimum wage. These are his main promises so far in economic matters,
but what would Biden's America look like? Well,
probably his first goal would be to undo what Trump has done.
This would include restoring the U S prominence among Western democracies and a
return to the multilateral strategy on the international stage.
I'm sure many Asian countries would be glad to see someone in Washington.
Finally looking beyond America. First in addition,
Biden has already spoken of returning to the nuclear agreement with Iran and of
signing the Paris agreement. Thank God. And of course, domestically,
as you could imagine, his choice would also have consequences.
For example,
the white house would almost certainly softened its discourse on illegal
immigration. In fact,
Biden wants to offer a path to citizenship for the 11 million undocumented
immigrants already living in the United States.
But a revolution cannot be expected either if the legislative elections of two
years ago proved anything. It's that in order to regain the presidency,
Democrats must attack from the center. If Biden wins,
he will surely dominates the house of representatives butts to have a majority
in the Senate.
Democrats would need to snatch three of the 23 Republican Senator seats that
will be in play in November.
And to have a super majority that would undo a blockage,
he would need more no less than 13 of those 23 senators,
a totally unlikely scenario,
unless there's an outright to the buckle for Trump and the Republican yeah.
Party.
Hold on a minute because while it may surprise us,
the truth is that Biden is counting on the Republicans.
It seems that his bet is after a hypothetical defeat of the current president,
the Republican party would recover a more centrist tone.
And let's not forget that he himself has always stood out as the type of
politician capable of bringing Democrats and Republicans together to push
through legislation. So the key question is what could he accomplish now?
Well.
Well, if you remember the video on Mitt Romney,
the Obamacare program was basically inspired by the earlier healthcare reform
agreement between Republicans and Democrats in the state of Massachusetts.
And if we add to that, to the impact of the current Corona virus pandemic,
I don't know,
it just doesn't seem like fantasy to think that any representative of the
Republicans could get behind an entire federal health pact.
Joe Biden's healthcare plan would spend $750 billion more on Obamacare and
cap drug place. Inflation.
Biden's plan is to offer a public option in healthcare. In this sense,
it would go further than what was put in place in Massachusetts by offering to
buy government health insurance,
the goal for millions of Americans to purchase this public insurance.
Do you have a large enough volume of policy holders to make this public option
affordable, sustainable and competitive with private insurance?
In addition by them wants to extend to the public Medicare program,
which guarantees health care for the elderly and disabled from the age of 60,
instead of the current 65 and friends, if both measures are implemented,
the future Biden administration would for better or worse transform American
healthcare, as we know it. And frankly,
it doesn't seem farfetched to think that such a plan could have the support of
many Republicans.
This is.
The only issue on which Biden is proposing a U-turn on Trump starts.
Biden's sets out $2 trillion plan for carbon free electricity by 2035.
Let's see.
Going from zero to a climate plan that invests $2 billion over four years.
I don't know. It's like going from classical music to death metal,
but I didn't propose is achieving a zero emissions economy by 2050 in order to
do so.
He is committed to electric vehicles promoting clean energy and supporting
research into technologies that capture CO2 from the atmosphere.
But hold on a moment because we've already told you that Biden plays for this
center and here you can see it again perfectly to give you an idea of Obama's
former vice president does not reject nuclear energy or fracking.
So I don't know,
is it so crazy to think that he could get the support of the Republicans for a
federal plan in this year?
Don't.
Forget that no one knows what the future holds. Not even.
Him, he's going to be your president because some people don't love me. Maybe.
In short extend medical care,
provide stimulus to deal with the crisis and establish a national policy towards
the reduction of carbon emissions. This is the Biden plan. In a nutshell,
you could take or leave those ideas, but they are not radical.
And if we take into account,
the Democrats eagerness to reach agreements with the opposition,
the result would probably not be any disruptive change.
Basically what Biden is proposing is simply to bring order to Washington.
But at this point, it's your turn.
What do you think of Joe Biden's election promises?
Do you think he will manage to defeat Trump? Leave your answer in the comments.
So I really hope you've enjoyed this video. Please hit, like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos,
don't forget to check out our friends over at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode, that one, not mine.
And also this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll be seeing you in the next week.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media. We have a
podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.
[Inaudible].